Catch tough right now. Catch much
easier. So this one idea will change how
you think about business. It's keep
simple but not the way you think.
Fundamentally it's about how to make a
more profitable business and doing this
from the top down from a strategy,
marketing, sales, product delivery
perspective. And I want to take you
through an exercise first and then I'll
talk about it afterwards. Let's imagine
that I have a marketing campaign and I
want you to understand some of the
benefits of my services or my product,
right? So, I might have four different
benefits that I think are really, you
know, really material that I want
someone to know. Okay? And so, the
problem is the vast majority of
marketing looks like this. Ready? One,
two, three.
Catch. Well, it's very hard to catch all
four at the same time. But if I just
said, "Hey, real quick, I want you to
understand something.
catch, you'd probably be able to catch
that. And so, it's a great visual
analogy for the value of a simple
message. Ken Seagull, who wrote the the
book uh Insanely Simple, talks about
this when he was in his meetings with
Steve Jobs, and that was an exercise
that he took the marketing team through.
Whenever they'd want to start saying
multiple points, it would he knew that
it would eventually devolve into every
single thing under the sun that we could
possibly say about this thing, which
meant that we hadn't done enough
strategic thinking around what is the
one thing that matters most. And so the
saying that they live by, which I really
love, find the most compelling point and
communicate it in the most compelling
way. I'll say that again because I think
it's so important. You focus on the one
most compelling point and then you
communicate it in the most compelling
way. A thousand songs in your pocket,
right? It's, I think, a discipline that
has to be taken pervasively from the top
down. It has to start with the business
owner, has to start with the CEO, has to
start with the founder, whoever person
is calling the shots in terms of what
we're doing as a business. Because this
level of simplicity, right, takes more
work than complexity. And that's what's
crazy about it is that complexity is
less work than simplicity. Because
complexity is typically the child of
lazy thinking. We can't prioritize.
We're not sure which one of these four
things is most important. So, we'll just
say them all. We have these four
features. Rather than limit it to one
and then make that one better, we're
just going to see all four because we
want to appeal to all sorts of different
people. But most really big business
ideas, in my opinion, are the opposite
of what you would naturally do. Because
if what people's natural instincts led
them to do were the things that made
businesses successful, then most people
would have successful businesses. And
that's anything but true. And so it's
the constraint of fig of forcing
yourself to say no. There are three
things here. There is one of these that
is more important. And we have to keep
whittling it down or chunking up the
language such that this one point is the
most compelling. And you're thinking,
okay, well, maybe this is just only
applies to marketing, right? No, it has
to go all the way through. Cuz think
about it. If you figure out that this
one core promise or core feature, right,
is the most important thing. Then that
informs our product strategy. What
features are we going to build? What
services are we going to deliver? And if
we only have one to do, wouldn't we
spend so much disproportionate amount of
time trying to make that thing
exceptional? Like you look at Raising
Canes, right? The chicken shop. They
have seven ingredients on the menu. like
they arguably couldn't have fewer
ingredients in order to make a meal.
They've got toast, they got fries,
they've got chicken tenders and then
they've got sauce and beverages. There's
six and there's one more. I can't
remember what it is, right? And so I
think kleslaw or something like that.
But anyways, point being they could like
someone saying, "Hey, have you
considered adding an eighth item?" Yeah,
they probably thought about it. But the
ability to say this is what matters
most. If we only did this one thing,
would we accomplish all of our goals?
And I think it's one of the most
powerful questions. Frank Frank Slutman
who wrote the the book Snowball talks
about this one thing where he says a lot
of companies will take you know they'll
have five objectives and 10 five
subobjectives and and they go into
subobjective you know nightmare right he
says if we cannot say what the one thing
that's most important in the business
then the job of the CEO that CEO has
failed and I'm guilty of this too so I'm
not saying this is not me saying this
from a pedestal this is me uh you know
this is me trying to document my own
thinking rather than say this is a
sermon is that what one thing if it were
true 12 months from now would change
everything for our business. And what's
interesting is that when you ask that
question, like what one thing would have
to be true? Like if we had a dedicated
lead channel that we owned, that one
thing would change everything. If we
just had a great supply of talent for
our HVAC company, for new technicians,
if we just did that by the end of the
year, it would change everything for us.
If we were just able to to to pull cash
flow from 90 days to to 30 days uh for
each sale that we do, that would change
everything for us. Thinking about that
as the what must be true then becomes
the most important business objective
because you might have objective 2 3 4
5. But if you just did one then it
likely makes 2 3 4 5 1 irrelevant. Two
by the time you accomplish number one 2
3 4 5 might have changed because you
will now have new resources and new
assets at your disposal. And so you're
basically trying to make a decision
about variables before the board has
changed from the decisions that you're
ultimately trying to make. And one of
the difficult parts and this is the this
is the really nefarious one. Once you
make that one simple decision like this
is the priority, this is what we're
doing. All systems go every department
seeks to make this one thing true about
our world so that it relates back to
this business. Sometimes solutions take
time. Sometimes you have to sit with the
pain of an unbuilt bridge without
building a second bridge. So let's say
you know that like let's use the
technician example. You're like man we
got the phone's ringing off the hook. I
could expand my practice. I could expand
my XYZ if I just had more talent to
deliver, right? Well, if you're in that
boat, you know, once you've realized
that, you might kick off some sort of
recruiting search. You might kick off
some sort of community or some sort of
play where you get referrals from all
these different networks uh that would
generate technicians for you or
internships or whatever, right? But the
thing is is one month in that still
might not really have happened as in
like you might not have this over you
this overflow of new talent in the
business, right? But you know that if
that one thing were true 12 months from
now, that's the only thing that matters.
And so the hardest part and this is a
lesson I'm kind of making this public so
that me sticking with it too is that
sometimes you have to let the little
fires burn is that like you could and
like we sometimes do and this is I'm
guilty of this. I will kick off a real
meaty solution to a big thing. Like if
we do this, this the only thing we have
to do and we'll crush it. But then
because I'm impatient in a human being,
I'll be like it's, you know, it's 30
days later and I'll be like, oh my god,
it's not solved yet. And then I'll want
to try and solve it another way. When in
reality, me trying to solve it in two or
three ways ends up just pulling
resources from the one way that I know
will work but will take time. And so I
would rather take the sure bets on the
thing that has the absolute highest
leverage impact on my business rather
than many small bets that might or might
not work because the thing is is like
this is the death by a thousand paper
cuts. And so it's it's that that one
thing that then also simplifies what
everyone's doing. So this is a absolute
highle strategy thinking process. But
what's really fascinating about this is
and so they talk about Steve Jobs. He
has this great comparison between art of
western and eastern art. And you're
like, where's he going with this? I'll
explain. So, western art when they when
most people imagine like creating art,
they think of a blank canvas, right? Or
a blank document. And so, then what you
do is you add to that document, right?
What's interesting is that the Eastern
philosophy is opposed to this. So, they
think of it as like you have this big
slab of jade. And so, all we're doing is
removing the excess to reveal the art or
the sculpture underneath. And so, it's
the difference between Eastern and
Western philosophy. And as it applies to
business, it's kind of the same way,
which is like when you delete everything
that sucks about a phone with what
remains is an iPhone. And so I think
about that with services a lot because a
lot of times it's so easy to just say
like, okay, well, I'm going to add more
to the canvas, right? But when you when
you think about it from from pulling
things away, it's like what are all the
distractions that I'm creating internal
my business, but also to my customers?
Because you think about that that that
that crumple of paper, right? If I say,
"I'm going to help you with this one
thing," then just help with that one
thing. That's it. And Jack Dorsey says
this, and I love this quote. He says,
"Perfect every detail and limit the
number of details." It's so elegant.
Like, if you're going to do it, do it
well. And the vast majority of things
you can't do. This has been such a a
struggle for me for my entire career
because the more capable you get, the
more resources you have at your
disposal, the more opportunities present
themselves, the more the harder it is to
consistently say no. Jobs also said,
"Focus is the the number of amazing
ideas that you say no to." Right? I'm
just as proud of the things we did as
the things we didn't do, is one of his
famous quotes. And so, the idea that
they liked saying over and over again
was amazingly simple and simply amazing.
How do we just think like, I'm just
gonna make one sandwich. And if I just
make this one sandwich to be the best
sandwich in the city, I will probably
have lines out the door. I don't need to
have 20 sandwiches because if I just
make this sandwich the best sandwich,
and I think about it from the the
experience of someone eating it, the
experience of them waiting for it, the
experience of them ordering it, how I
source the ingredients, how those are
going to get combined, at what
temperature, in what order, right? who's
going to be the one providing them? how
like what are the price points in like
all of these types of things are it's
the obsession on the details but we're
limit because you can't go deep if you
have too many things and fundamentally
that's the problem is like myself
included we all have too many things
going on and you just can't go that deep
when you're spread too thin and the
thing is is that all of the outsized
returns come on the end of the curve
right so it's like you do this work do
this work do this work and it's only
when you're like okay I'm I'm at the 50%
mark meaning I'm like about average,
right? And you're at the 75% mark.
You're above average. You maybe do a
little bit better, right? But not not
that much better. You're at the 90%
mark. Okay, now we're starting to see
it. But the difference between 90th
percentile, 95th percentile, boom.
Between 95th and 99, boom. In terms of
who captures the market, who's the one
that people just can't help but say good
things about you, right? And so I just
think about what are these need to
believes? What are the things that if I
if I just did one thing, and if you're
thinking about this, you're like, well,
there's a lot of things that if I did
this, it would grow my business. We're
not thinking increments. We're thinking
orders of magnitude. So yes, if you
improve your sales close rate, you would
your business would grow. If you bumped
your, you know, margin by certain
percent, your business would grow. If
you if you increase your lead, sure, the
business would grow. But I'm not talking
about those improvements. Those are what
I consider the sausage making a
business. That's the daily. That's the
in-n-out. That's just like how you run a
business. I'm talking about what are the
orders of magnitude changes, the bets
that we're going to make with our
additional resources. Because
fundamentally, let's say you've got, you
know, a hundred people who work for you.
It could be 10, it could be one, doesn't
matter. The point is that you have x
amount of people work for you. Maybe
they're at 70% utilization or 80%
utilization. They've got a little bit
little bit of bandwidth on top of the
sausage making they have to do every day
to keep the keep the trains going. So
you have to scoop that little 20 30%,
right? And you have one real bet that
you can make on it. And so it's like you
want to make that bet worth it. What's
interesting is like how do you how do
you come up with these ideas, right? And
so I think this level of like how do we
just remove everything that doesn't
matter? And I trying to reverse my
thinking process this way. This is a lot
like um Munger's uh invert like okay if
I wanted to destroy my business what
would I do? Like it's a really powerful
frame. This is a different frame which
is how much can I take away and still
have it be good and not only be good but
it probably is better. And so I'll give
you a real world example. Uh in the
school games uh we we basically used to
have more calls that we did and we had
more stuff that we put in the community.
We had like three a week and then we
also had like content was getting dumped
in there and basically the number one
reason that people were cancelling was
overwhelm. It was not oh I need to
provide more value. It was I need to
provide more value per second in fewer
total seconds. And so rather than say,
okay, so what we did was we removed two
of the three calls, except kept it to
one and we moved the big download from
once a month to once a quarter so that
people could get on top of it, right?
And we removed some of the things that
were native and turned on inside of the
app so that people would have fewer
things to do when they got in. So they
were like, "Oh my god, there's so many
things I have to do. I can't think about
it." And then they leave, right? And so
we want kind of like you want to like
you only introduce something when it's
required or necessary for that person to
get the the desired value rather than
say here's all the different things you
can do. It's like well why don't we just
do this one thing that most people find
valuable first and then perfect that
step and then once we've done that maybe
we'll show the next step. If you're
actually subscribing to this this
ideology, which is something that I'm
really trying hard to I'd say like the
inversion process is how I've made a lot
of strategic decisions and I'm also
thinking more and more often with this
this frame of one, which is if I can't
decide what the one most important thing
is, then I'm not doing my job and I need
to think about it longer because the
thing is is that one provides more
efficiency than just about any strategy.
You want to cut costs, you want to
improve your margins, do one thing.
There's way fewer things to do. And if
you do one thing, you also need to have
way fewer meetings about it because
there's only one thing. And when you
have just one thing, you don't need to
have lots of people at the meetings. You
just have a very small group of very
smart people. And fundamentally, that's
how these projects start to get
organized. And the easiest way to screw
up a project like this is to give it too
much time. And so if it is simple, you
can also do it faster. So you could say
in 12 weeks and it doesn't what's crazy
about this is that you can do projects
even at like huge company levels in 12
weeks because you have more resources,
right? And so just thinking what is the
one thing that matters most? If I'm not
sure, what are all the things that I can
delete away and have it still be
valuable? And if I do know what that one
thing is, how deep on that one thing can
I go? Because if I made this one thing
true at the end of the year, all of my
other problems would shrink into
irrelevance. They would no longer
matter. It makes the the noise go down.
But the thing is is that you have to
subscribe to this philosophy through and
through. Like you have to believe in it
balls to bones because you think you're
overwhelmed. I promise your team's 10
times more overwhelmed because they
don't know what direction you're in
because you're changing it all the time
because you have so many different
conflicting priorities. And so having
this focus of one is easy to
communicate. People remember it because
it's only one crumpled piece of paper,
right? It's easy to sell because it's
one thing and you can just make that
point as compelling as humanly possible.
When you're delivering on product or
services, you just perfect that one
result, that one deliverable. A lot of
marketing agents just expand and expand
and expand their breath of like what
they do. All these different services
they tack on, tack on tack on. Right
now, if you're in an enterprise value
business, those companies, if you're
serving Fortune 100, it's a little bit
of an use case there because for them,
the one thing is full integration,
right? like that would be the chunked up
one thing for that business, right? If
they actually had one person that could
globally support their business, then
that would be the one big thing we try
and solve for, right? Um but many
businesses, it's like if you just got
them leads consistently, they would be
happy. Like you don't need to offer
these other other services, the other
quote value benefits, because if you
just did the one thing that mattered,
they wouldn't care about anything else.
And I remember there was this moment in
gym launch when we had um a handful of
gym owners reach out and say, "Hey, can
we hop on a call?" And I said, "Sure."
and uh you know we're like hey we're
trying to improve the product blah blah
and they just like cut us off and they
were like we just need leads like just
more leads that's it like if you just
give us more leads we'll be happy and so
it was one of those like you know it's
it's uh it's the economy stupid right
it's kind of like the present like if
you just fix the one thing that matters
and if I'm if it sounds like I'm
hammering this a lot it's because I'm
hammering it into my own brain and if
you think of like if you were to
deconstruct this like I love this little
quote of uh to achieve great things two
ingredients are needed a plan and not
enough time. And so it forces you to
prioritize so that you can actually do
the things that matter most. And I think
that this is something that I'm trying
to artificially do. You see like Elon
talk about this for those you hate Elon
just pretend he's cool for this
conversation. Um you're also wrong.
Anyways, point being, if you see the
rate of innovation that they're able to
do across the companies that he owns, a
big part of it, he talks, is
accelerating timelines, which is making
unreasonable goals because the
unreasonable goals create a forcing
function for performance. And this has
also been uh Brian Chesy talks about
this from Airbnb. There's a bunch of
other Y cominator founders who talk
about this where they're like, if you
want to speed up something happening,
number one, big public goal, number two,
make it really aggressive on timeline.
Number three, check up frequently.
Number four, remove people who shouldn't
be on the project because they just
create more communication cycles and
more waste and more people to talk and
and get, you know, approvals from.
Fundamentally, you have to make bets and
sometimes you just have to let people go
as in like let them work, let them cook,
right? Because if you get out of their
way, a lot of times if you have a clear
goal, clear objective, you're checking
in regularly, you don't need to do much
more than that. And so this is something
that I'm half shouting at myself um as a
reminder of the few things that matter
most. And if I do not have that one
thing for my team, then I have failed,
not them. So that is my insanely simple.
It's been top of mind because I I just
read a couple books that mention jobs
recently. It's been really valuable for
me. And so when I'm thinking about my
own marketing campaigns, I'm like, what
is the one most compelling thing I can
bring up? And how can I say that one
thing in the most compelling way? Hey,
if you enjoyed this, uh, I had one of my
best presentations of all time where I
talk about how to accelerate how you get
to your goals, whether they be
financial, physical, whatever, um, by
focusing on leverage. And so, it's the
the first real presentation I made after
basically getting into this whole
YouTube world. Um, and it was just kind
of like compiled from years of me
thinking about wealth creation. And if
that's at all interesting to you, you
can click and watch it here. And dry.